d'abord donc on dévoile les résultats ce
baromètre opodo que ça mascaret pour les
chaînes parlementaires et la presse
régionale avec cécile 6e pas d'état de
grâce pour emmanuel macron le président
débute son mandat plus impopulaire qui
après son élection de 2010 7 44% des
français estiment qu'il est un bon
président ils étaient 58 % en 2017 c'est
le deuxième mandat d'emmanuel macro et
donc l'effet de surprise ne joue plus
mais par ailleurs emmanuel macron
beaucoup d'observateurs l'ont souligné
pendant la campagne présidentielle n'a
pas vraiment fait campagne sauf entre
les deux tours et donc l'électorat d'une
certaine manière n'a pas pu se saisir
véritablement du sens car ce deuxième
mandat d' emmanuel macron avec born la
nouvelle première ministre ne fait pas
mieux sa cote de popularité est de 43 %
- derrière les scores d'edouard philippe
au moment de sa nomination en 2017 qui
avait 55 % d'opinions favorables
pour elisabeth bornes sans aucun doute
il y a un effet de la longueur avec
laquelle sa nomination a été a été
annoncé aux français une sorte de faux
suspense s'est déroulée et les français
n'ont pas du tout le sentiment que le
casting du nouveau gouvernement surprend
ou en tout cas qu'il incarne cette
fameuse nouvelle méthode de gouvernement
car annoncé emmanuel macron outre
constat au sein du gouvernement seuls
quelques ministres sont connus des
français olivier ferrand bruno le maire
et gabriela talent il figure parmi les
dix personnalités politiques les plus
appréciés avec 33 32 et 27 % d'opinions
favorables au fond du classement damien
abad le ministre des solidarités accusé
de viol et 30 sujet l'air il enregistre
seulement 8% adhésion enfin les autres
nouveaux ministres souvent inconnus
suscite surtout la différence dans la
pierre
voilà et on analyse tout les résultats
de ce baromètre avec mes invités alexa
germond bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes sa
présidente du cercle de réflexion france
audacieuse j'accueille également pablo
pino vivien bonsoir pablo bonsoir est
amené à vous aussi responsable éditorial
de la revue regards
erwan lestrohan bonsoir bon sens vous
êtes directeur conseil à l'institut de
sondage aux hawks a et donc vous allez
voile a détaillé le résultat de ce
baromètre pour nous on est également en
duplex avec benjamin grange quel
président de la société mascaret qui
scrute pour ce baromètre bonsoir
benjamin les réseaux sociaux pour nous
les réseaux sociaux les médias sociaux
et les tice aqlpa et nettoyer 160 soir
laetitia bienvenus le premier constat
erwan lestrohan c'est que effectivement
il n'ya pas d'état de grâce pour
l'exécutif voilà c'est inédit sous la
vème république on a un président qui
commence son mandat avec moins de 50% de
bonnes opinions c'est inédit parce que
en mai 2010 7 58% des français jugé que
c'était un bon président c'est beaucoup
plus haut mais il en était de même pour
françois hollande 61 % en mai 2012 pour
nicolas sarkozy 57% en mai 2007 et on
retrouve le même constat même pour
jacques chirac en 2002 quand il est
réélu pour françois mitterrand en 1988
quand il est réélu à ceci près que ces
deux présidents donc le françois
mitterrand et jacques chirac a vu la
respiration citoyenne et démocratique
d'une cohabitation aujourd'hui c'est un
nouveau mandat qui commence avec la
volonté d'un nouveau souffle mais sans
une nouvelle dynamique ça montre un peu
les difficultés de gouvernabilité qui
peuvent se poser pour emmanuel macron
sert qu'à qu'un soutien limité dans
l'opinion et une feuille de route
ambitieuse au niveau des réformes c'est
plus difficile d'imposer ses réformes
aux français que quand on a une marge de
manoeuvre et un état de grâce qui permet
d'imposer un rythme de réformes plus
soutenu dès le début de l'entrée en
fonction des eaux qu'effectivement il
est nettement moins populaire que
à la sortie de son de sa première
élection vous nous l'avez dit mais il
progresse quand même par rapport au mois
de mars dernier après il y à une quatre
points ils gagnent un peu de tous les
côtés si on regarde chez les
sympathisants ps il fait plus 10 points
chez les sympathisants et l'air il fait
+11 points donc c'est quoi c'est un peu
en demi teinte comme absolument réaliser
exactement ça vous avez raison c'est un
entre deux parfait il progresse auprès
des sympathisants et c'est un message
aussi pour la nuit baisse auprès des
sympathisants ps des sympathisants
europe ecologie les verts est lui aussi
un bon niveau de popularité auprès des
sympathisants et l'air dans ces trois
populations il est autour des 50% de
bonnes opinions et l'autre point
important qui souligne qu'il est
vraiment dans un entre deux c'est que il
a démarré à 58 % en mai 2010 est il a
connu son niveau le plus bas à 27% en
pleine crise des gilet jaune en décembre
2018 la situe à 44 % donc vraiment dans
cet entre deux qui montre que il reste
quand même au dessus est très nettement
au-dessus son score plancher des gilets
jaunes mais il reste quand même élargir
sa marge de manoeuvre pour imposer ses
réformes et faire peut-être de la
pédagogie autour de sa feuille de route
auprès des français alors on y reviendra
jours et qu'on parle maintenant de
d'elisabeth bornes avec ces éléments
dont il sut de du baromètre
43 % de popularité avec là aussi si on
regarde du côté de des sympathisants ps
et et elle est alors on on est à 48 %
chez les sympathisants ps et 52% chez
les verts les républiques alexa germond
est ce que vous diriez que c'est un
début un peu poussif pour la première
ministre s'est elle a besoin de
s'installer dans le paysage politique
avec cette nouvelle
nouvelle et a finalement ce que je
trouve très intéressant dans cette
nomination
bon c'est vrai ça a été dit par bruno
cautrès certainement le fait qu'il y ait
eu un peu de retard à l'allumage dans l'
annonce n'a pas permis cet effet de
souffle que l'on a d'habitude avec la
nomination d'un gouvernement en revanche
c'était le un peu le premier nom qui
était sorti dans la presse donc on a
bouclé la boucle
cela dit ce qui est intéressant c'est
que dans le ce parcours d'une femme avec
des valeurs de gauche en même qui a été
très marqué à gauche au début de sa
carrière politique et professionnelle on
voit dans votre sondage qu'en fait elle
a une assez bonne perception notamment
chez les élèves vous le disiez à 52 par
rapport à 48 alors c'est pas énorme non
plus mais ça montre quand même que le
lot fils qu'elle a eu à tenir finalement
pendant le premier quinquennat d'
emmanuel macron qui était plutôt vécu
comme sur des valeurs de droite avec des
réformes de droite fait que là aussi on
retrouve cet entre-deux ou 7 en même
temps mac rognan vous avez une
personnalité plutôt marquée à gauche qui
résonne assez bien chez avec cette
notion de compétence et de légitimité et
on lui laisse sa chance évidemment pour
voir de quelle façon elle va mener ce
gouvernement c'est ça qui est assez
intéressant je trouve dans cette
nomination qui en tout cas montre qu'
elle est légitime à cette place là elle
est légitime et ça ce sont je ne sais
pas si vous l'avez testé ou pas mais ça
fait partie des éléments en tout cas
quand vous êtes sur le terrain qui sont
remontées en dix ans maintenant on
attend de voir pablo pino vient
effectivement l as well as pas eu le
temps d'imprimer sa marque elizabeth
bornes il faut il faut le reconnaître
mais c'est aussi le contexte
électorale qui qui joue et qui
l'empêchent peut-être aussi d'imprimer
sa marque c'est à dire que effectivement
comme l'a dit bruno cautrès ça a mis
énormément de temps ce n'était pas une
surprise à l'arrivée et surtout pour
l'instant elle a absolument rien fait
enfin la seule chose qu'elle a eu
véritablement à gérer c'est la sphère
damien abad dont vous parlerez dans la
deuxième partie qui à mon avis a aussi
peut-être joué un peu dans l'image que
les français on une telle mais c'est
surtout l'absence en fait de décisions
et de et de décrets et 2 et 2 fin de
quoi que ce soit en fait pendant un mois
c'est à dire que fofora puis je crois
que vous avez fait votre sondage la
semaine dernière c'était enfin votre
étude le 25 mai c'est à dire plus d'un
mois après le premier tour à la fin du
deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle et je suis bien en peine
en fait de dire ce qu'a fait le
l'action en fait de notre exécutif
depuis depuis cette date là c'est
absolument néant à part la faire à
badens est là depuis le week-end dernier
la question du stade de france qui sont
quand même deux choses qui viennent
vraiment mais c'est le harnais l'image
aux polémiques là on est soulagés
sérieusement de la gestion de crise
alors même que les français et les
françaises attendent énormément ont
besoin en fait d'actions concrètes
notamment et on en parle très souvent
dans les médias mais on entend aussi sur
le terrain la question du pouvoir
d'achat le blocage des prix qu'est ce
qu'on fait avec l'inflation en fait sur
tous ces sujets là il attendait des
mesures est pour l'instant absolument
rien des prix est prévue début juillet
mais c'est prévu début juillet le prime
c'est que les français il y aurait dix
ont déjà dû vous avez effectivement un
ou deux décrets et pas forcément alors
c'est compliqué parce qu'il fait notre
finances rectificative et c est pour
l'instant l'agenda est quand même assez
floue enfin j'ai toujours pas très bien
compris sur la question vous dit que ça
va être début juillet ya la question de
la réforme des retraites on nous dit que
ça va arriver à la rentrée mais en fait
on n'est pas vraiment sûr de quelle
forme ça va prendre ils ont toujours pas
été clair en fait sur les mesures qu'il
voulait prendre alors justement je me
tourne vers benjamin grange pour pour
savoir comment le cette idée pouvoir
d'achat elle ressort dans les médias
sociaux est ce que ça reste quand même
le le thème qui écrase tout comme on l'a
vécu pendant l'élection présidentielle
alors c'est vrai qu'il ya deux thèmes
qui dominent dans les réseaux sociaux
quand on parle finalement de politiques
et du gouvernement le premier je crois
qu'on l'a on l'a déjà pas mal évoqué
c'est c'est finalement qu'est ce que va
faire ce gouvernement qui ressemble
comme qui ressemble énormément au
précédent et c'est vrai que entre le nom
suspense d'elisabeth bornes que les
français commencent eux à découvrir et
puis ce sentiment de près de 2 de
continuité qui qui prédomine finalement
on se retrouve autour d'un d'un vrai
questionnement sur quelle politique va
t'il va-t-il mener et en coin de ce
gouvernement sera vraiment différent du
précédent et c'est ça aujourd'hui qui
qui entretient beaucoup les
conversations conversation et puis
évidemment en toile de fond on va
retrouver ce sujet du pouvoir d'achat ce
sujet du pouvoir d'achat sur les 30
derniers jours il est presque trois fois
plus important dans les conversations
que il n'était avant alors il n'est pas
comment il n'est pas à son apogée qu'on
avait finalement au moment de la
campagne présidentielle on la campagne
dont il était omniprésent c'était
presque un tiers des sujets qui tournait
de près ou de loin sur le pouvoir
d'achat là on n'est pas du tout à ces
niveaux là mais on retrouve au fond les
on retrouve les niveaux que l'on avait
par exemple en octobre ou en novembre
dernier était déjà extrêmement important
et surtout c'est qu'on voit les signaux
faibles que d'un mouvement qui monte
pas encore évidemment de signes lié à
une forme de radicalité ou de ou de
passage à l'acte comme on l'a vu avec
les gilet jaune mais en tout cas c'est
un mouvement qui est vraiment
extrêmement présents aujourd'hui et
probablement avec plus d'impatience que
ce que le gouvernement
ce qu'elle nous la vitesse à laquelle le
gouvernement réagit intéressant
effectivement d'avoir ce ce retour des
réseaux sociaux l'istia vous avez trouvé
un nom pour comprendre la stratégie de
communication de d'emmanuel mâcon dans
cette campagne 10 l'atvs allons bon
c'est la stratégie du flipper et
thomas c'est simple je pense que tous
autant la table on al'âge d'abord jouer
au flipper j'espère que ça parle encore
aux nouvelles générations quand vous
jouer au flipper tirez vous armer la
boule en tirant le petit bitonio la
bienvenue ça comme ça et ensuite vous
lâcher et la boule part dans tous les
sens à grande vitesse et bien je vous
fait grâce bien sûr du titre un des
années 80 de corinne charby qu'on a tous
dans la tête
et donc c'est exactement la stratégie d'
emmanuel macron entre cette période des
élections
présidentielles de l'élection
présidentielle et des élections
législatives c'est celle de tirer ce
ressort du flipper pour mettre le paquet
ensuite la boule des réformes partira à
vous l'avez dit alexia début juillet
juste après les élections législatives
et avant l'été là il y aura un gros
paquet de réformes notamment sur le
pouvoir d'achat alors est-ce que c'est
aussi une façon d'éviter les critiques
oui exactement c'est ce que l'elysée a
théorisé en tous les cas c'est à dire
que il retient et ils pratiquent cette
stratégie de la rareté de la parole
emmanuel macron fait un déplacement
aujourd'hui et puis il ira aussi à
marseille jeudi mais pour le moment vous
avez raison pablo dans le mois qui vient
de s'écouler on l'a quasiment pas
entendu sur les questions intérieures
évidemment sur la politique
internationale étaient toujours présents
mais c'est fait exprès c'est à dire que
comme cela il n'y a aucune prise
possible pour l'opposition donc on évite
les critiques et on surf le plus
possible sur le succès de l'élection
présidentielle or il ya quand même un
risque dans tout cela c'est de
finalement sauté une étape qui est
pourtant incontournable celle de la
réparation du lien démocratique et pour
vous expliquer cette réparation là je
vais utiliser les mots d'un
ex-conseiller d'emmanuel mâcon qui donc
le connais très bien son ancienne plume
sylvain fort c'est lui qui en parle le
mieux c'était dans l'express en début de
mois début de mois de mai il dit le
nouveau quinquennat avance sur un champ
de cendres cette campagne présidentielle
n'a pas fait émerger l'armée
enthousiaste de l'an 2 elle nous a
placés face au gouffre c'est passionnant
ça parce que ça pose la question de la
façon dont les ministres
les nouveaux et les anciens d'ailleurs
dont les ministres ont reçu ce manque
d'enthousiasmé vous le vous le recevez
dans la perception de ce gouvernement
voilà c'est moi que c'est faire
l'exécutif là on va se concentrer sur
les ministres mais c'est vrai que c'est
l'une des tendances 1 de ce début de
quinquennat où finalement on attendait
un certain changement dans la continuité
pour l'instant les français ont vu la
continuité pas forcément le changement
c'est vraiment ce qui ressort des
enquêtes et puis une certaine apathie un
certain manque d'enthousiasmé les
ministres qui arrive ou qui sont
reconduits on peut les classer en quatre
groupes aujourd'hui en termes de
popularité un premier groupe des
ministres qui ont un solde d'image
positif qui sont plutôt soutenu
c'est bruno le maire c'est olivier
ferrand c'est gabriel attal ses trois
ministres là sont ceux qui disposent du
socle du mage le plus favorable deux
autres ministres sont bien connus mais
suscite plus de rejet c'est gérald
darmanin et eric dupond moretti enfin on
a des ministres comme sébastien lecornu
comme catherine colonna comme pape
diagne qui pour l'instant sont encore
relativement méconnu des pages blanches
un peu dans l'opinion sur lesquels les
français vont construire une image mais
qui ne suscite pas de rejet et d'autres
ministres soit parce qu'ils sont liés au
pouvoir exécutif et au précédent
quinquennat comme stanislas guérini ou
encore amélie de montchalin ou encore
parce qu'ils ont été au coeur d'une
certaine agitation médiatique comme
damien abad non seulement sont
relativement méconnu mais en plus
suicide du rouge est donc pour l'instant
n'a vraiment ces quatre catégories de
ministres là on va voir comment les
choses vont se transformer dans les
prochaines semaines et puis on parlait
d' absence de dynamique pour emmanuel
macron il ya aussi toute la question de
la victoire ou non aux législatives et
de l'effet de souffle qu'elle peut
générer en 2010 est ce qu'on observait
c'est que les choses étaient
parfaitement stable c'est à dire que la
victoire aux législatives de la
république en marche n'est pas susciter
de regain d'intérêt pour le projet
présidentiel on verra si c'est
susceptible de regonfler la mobilisation
des français c'est aussi l'un des enjeux
de ces législatives qui arrive benjamin
grange comment ces nouveaux entrants ils
sont perçus sur les réseaux sociaux
tiens je propose qu'on fasse un zoom sur
le le nouveau ministre de l'éducation
nationale je regarde le détail de la
cote d'adhésion de pap ndiaye dans dans
le baromètre doxa mascaret on est à 20 %
d'adhésion pour 31% de rejet comment le
nouveau ministre de l'éducation
nationale et puis peut-être plus
généralement les nouveaux entrants sont
ils perçus sur les médias sociaux jama
grange ben en fait on l'a dit la
relative continuité en fait de ce
gouvernement elle questionne sur les
ministres qui sont entre ans et ceux qui
sont sortants et peut-être ceux
d'ailleurs qui sont en sursis et
concernant en tout cas le le poste de
l'éducation il ya une vraie question qui
porte sur pourquoi jean michel blanquer
at il était recalé pour sa réforme pour
le bac ou est ce que il n'avait plus
envie et ça c'est un c'est déjà un
élément de questionnements que les
internautes auront et puis évidemment ça
c'est en creux mais en plein il ya son
remplaçant et son remplaçant il est
vraiment perçu à l'opposé idéologique de
son prédécesseur souvent vu comme pour
ceux qui le connaissent quelqu'un de
deux peut-être de plus dans la culture
web et st là encore ça questionne de
pourquoi ce grand écart par rapport à
eux
quelqu'un qui était vu jean michel
blanquer de sérieux de police et de 2,2
méthodique de construit dit mais
pourquoi
pourquoi finalement maintenant changer
totalement de deux castings et puis
globalement cette ce questionnement il
se poursuit évidemment sur sur les
autres ministres en d'autres termes la
mise en retrait de la république devant
m6 ap un personnage plutôt apprécié est
ce durable le garde des sceaux est il
sur un siège éjectable
et puis finalement et on revient avec
eux sur le sujet damien abad dans la
polémique sur les accusations
d'agressions sexuelles est tous un peu
les sujets programmatique en pleine
législatives et bien fait-il l'objet
d'un complot politique ou d'un lâchage
du gouvernement ça aussi c'est comme ça
aujourd'hui en tout cas que l'on parle
de lui et des principaux ministres
nouveau ce gouvernement tout petit
élément peut-être une hypothèse 1 pour
répondre à cette légère apathie sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est que pareil plein
pap ndiaye rim adoul malak et sylvie
retailleau ont tout juste créé leur
compte twitter il n'était pas sur les
réseaux sociaux il faut bien avoir une
existence sur les réseaux sociaux pour
avoir une certaine popularité est à
paraître dans les discussions ils
viennent de le créer leur compte twitter
donc je ne sais pas si c'est une
obligation qui vient peut-être du
service de d'information du gouvernement
de matinaux de l'elysée en tous les cas
vous remarquerez que tous ont
aujourd'hui un compte twitter et que
beaucoup de nouveaux arrivants viennent
de le créer pablo pino vivien cette
nomination de pap ndiaye pour l'instant
elle n'est que symbolique là aussi il
n'y a pas eu d'annoncé a plus de réforme
y à rien oui allez ali uniquement semble
y tenir en fait je vais je en fait je
n'agis pas tellement de choses à dire
sur la nomination de pap ndiaye dans la
mesure où on ne connaît absolument pas
la nature du projet qu'il va proposer
pour l'éducation nationale
c'est qu'il est déjà perçue dans ce
j'allais dire sa caricature d'une
certaine façon en tout cas dans laxe de
sécurité critiques ont été exprimées en
tous les cas c'est vrai qu'il représente
un peu le leu leu leu leu pendant
complètement à l'opposé de ce que
représentait jean michel blanquer et que
ça interroge parce que ça n'a pas été
justifiée c'est à dire qu'on pensait que
au sein de la macro ni jean michel
branquart et amis ce qui était plutôt
apprécié et là tout d'un coup on se rend
compte que bailly les îles et enfin
comment dire remplacer par son exact
opposé
idéologiquement donc c'est vrai que ça
pour le coup ça laisse perplexe
après on va voir dans quelle mesure
enfin c'est ce qui va mener mais
j'aimerais juste revenir sur une chose
c'est qu'en fait toutes les questions
qu'on se pose sa pose la question de
est-ce que l'on peut gouverner en étant
impopulaire et ça vaut pour emmanuel
macron ça vaut pour les différents
membres
gouvernement et je pense que cette
question parce que pour l'instant ils
ont emmanuel macron à la légitimité
institutionnelle il a été élu il va peu
de sûrement dans les projets de son
siège il aura certainement la majorité à
l'assemblée nationale et pour autant les
différents membres de son gouvernement
la macro ni pourrait continuer à avoir
des codes du popularité qui ne sont pas
si bonne que ça et donc cette question
qui est une question qui est
profondément qui est à la fois
démocratique qui pose la question de
tous ces baromètres et toutes ses études
dans quelle mesure elles peuvent
interférer finalement avec la conduite
en fait d'une politique pour lesquelles
ces différentes personnes à la fois le
président et les députés auront été élus
ça pose des questions parce que là en
fait on est en fête avec cette étude
vous êtes en train de faire naître mais
vous n'êtes pas les salles et je ne
remet pas du tout en question la façon
la méthodologie de votre votre étude
mais en fait j'étais en train de faire
naître l'idée selon laquelle emmanuel
macron serai un président impopulaire
la vérité
c'est le chat non mais si je sais que
c'est un peu chien qui se mord la queue
mais en fait au bout d'un moment fait à
dire en sans arrêt c'est un président
impopulaire est à dire que les mises
sont impopulaires et à la macro ni tabou
parce que j'ai une marge de ce que j'ai
ressenti le réformer
c'est que le dogme du du 50% d'opinions
favorables en dessous de quoi on est
impopulaire et atteint peut-être ses
limites dans un paysage politique qui
est multi polarisé parce qu'on le voit
bien on le voit bien il ya une
balkanisation des préférences politiques
entre eux l'extrême droite d'un côté la
gauche plus radicale d'un autre côté du
grand parti
central donc serré sarroise espace
politique qui représentent chacun grosso
modo un tiers de l'électorat donc cette
barre de 50% elle ne s'adresse pas
forcément à bien comprendre leurs
préférences électorales pour autant on
est dans un système
présidentiel où le président est élu à
50% des voix plus une donc cette barre
des 50% elle a quand même un sens même
si je vous rejoins c'est vrai que dans
un espace politique qui est très pauvre
multi polarisée ça peut poser question à
l'excès de nombreux commentaires me
viennent à l'esprit
d'abord c'est le meilleur je ne sais pas
mais en tout cas la première chose c'est
qu'on voit qu'il ya eu un glissement de
terrain où on est passé de quelque chose
qui était simplement pas d'état de grâce
à un sentiment d'impopularité c'est pas
la même chose et c'est parce qu'on est
en train de dire et de plus il me semble
que pour faire une analyse qui soient
pertinentes
il faut pas qu'on reste sur une photo
prise macro est extrêmement immobile
permettre c'est le premier point de
l'étude début de leur mandat dans l'ain
on était quand même sur plutôt un état
de grâce qui n'étaient pas là mais ce
qui était intéressant dans l'étude c'est
qu'on voyait quand même le l'évolution
qui était là et il y avait une double
évolution l'évolution par rapport aux
extrêmes où on voit que les extrêmes
reculent en même temps perdre au moment
des législatives et vous l'avez très
bien dit tout à l'heure en fait il est
entre deux entre deux ça veut aussi dire
qu'il reste au milieu du jeu et qu'il y
a encore des possibilités
d'aller grappiller et de reconcentrer de
rassembler à nouveau une
majorité qui partaient un petit peu de
façon
et parce donc là en fait on est encore
et moi c'est ce que je ressent sur le
terrain je trouve que c'est ça qui est
intéressant c'est quand les deux se
recoupent finalement c'est que les
français aujourd'hui ils sont d'abord
extrêmement préoccupée par le traîne
donc il ya le problème de la fracture
démocratique
certes vous avez les législatives où
pour l'instant c'est vrai les gens sont
encore très loin alors que c'est dans
deux semaines mais il ya une vraie
inquiétude de terrain sur l'ukraine est
juste après le pouvoir d'achat les deux
étant mélangés très rapidement dans les
dents les conversations et on a un
dernier point je finirai par ça mais
aussi le sentiment des français qui est
le fait qu' on n'a pas forcément une
cartographie totalement sécurisée
aujourd'hui puisque vous avez des
ministres qui se présentent aux
suffrages et que ça peut bouger mais
peut y avoir ni peuvent ne pas être élu
et non conduire et céline est donc
aujourd'hui vous êtes dans une dans un
sentiment de deux temporalités entre
parenthèse avant d'avoir à partir du 19
juin une vision claire pour lancer le
paquet mais n'empêche que emmanuel
macron on sait qu'il restera voilà en
quels que soient son gouvernement bien
sûr que je ne comprends pas je vous
l'expliquais impatience a été théorisée
encore une fois par l'exécutif
maintenant de mon point de vue personnel
je ne comprends absolument pas ni son
discours de victoire très profil bas
très humble on comprend l'esprit on
comprend qu'il ne veut pas claironner
sur une victoire qu'il aurait peut-être
mal acquise parce que tous les français
n'ont pas voté pour lui je comprends
mais ensuite il faut quand même expliqué
thomas il faut expliquer le cap il faut
expliquer ce qu'on va faire il reçut ce
prix qu est ce qu avec le roman national
ça a été son obsession les cinq
dernières années il faut expliquer aux
français sans rentrer dans le détail des
réformes mais simplement donner encore
une la visibilité voilà ce qu'on va
faire avec l'ukraine par exemple voilà
mon projet en fait on n'a aucun projet
et sa campagne a été éclair il a
vraiment éludé à chaque fois l'exposé
encore une fois de de son projet et donc
je comprends ce flou et cet inconfort
dans lequel se retrouvent les français
on va parler maintenant des élections
législatives avec jonathan dû plier l on
le disait c'est dans c'est dans moins de
deux semaines cédant rays jour bonsoir
jonathan est ce que les français s'y
intéresse eh bien écoutez on serait
tenté de dire que non vu le climat
ambiant et le manque d enthousiasme qui
semble être dans l'air et pourtant le
baromètre doxa pour les chaînes
parlementaires que l'on vous révèle
aujourd'hui est un peu plus nuancé que
ça vous allez le voir
72 perceuse pour cent des personnes
interrogées indices s'intéresser au
scrutin alors ça peut paraître élevé
comme chiffres mais c'est en réalité
quatre points en dessous de 2017 et dans
le détail de ces 72 % seuls 33% disent
s'y intéresser beaucoup alors si les
français s'intéressent au scrutin ça ne
veut pas forcément dire que ça les
passionne non plus législatif ça peut
ressembler à une sorte d' usine à gaz
pour certains avec 577 circonscriptions
comme autant de batailles électorales à
suivre et puis le tout sur deux tours
mais est encore faut-il savoir qui est
candidat dans sa circonscription
oui et là non plus ce n'est pas
forcément très simple il ya 6293
candidat pour être exact et au dos que
ça relève que seuls 34% des personnes
interrogées disent bien les connaître
dans leur circonscription et quand 66%
ne les connaissent pas vraiment voilà
ces chiffres qui permettent de tempérer
un petit peu ce cet intérêt des conseils
à un autre signe c'est la prévision de
l'abstention oui pour rappel thomas ce
chiffre en 2010 7 53 57 3 % des français
n'étaient pas allés voter au second tour
des législatives est donc cette semaine
le baromètre doxa anticipe une
abstention un petit peu moins élevé
qu'il ya cinq ans mais qui reste tout de
même assez forte 1 53% pour le scrutin
des 12 et 24 juin avec quelques
subtilités politiques à décrypter
écouter galles et slimane
et des choses à lire en creux aussi
l'abstention est structurellement plus
fort pour des raisons sociologiques
auprès des électeurs de l'extrême droite
et de la gauche et extrême gauche plutôt
qu'auprès des électeurs du bloc du
centre qui sont plus âgés qui sont plus
enclins à voter cette fois ci le coup
réalisé par jean luc mélenchon et la
nuit baisse permet aux électeurs de
gauche d'être un peu plus nombreux à
envisager de s'abstenir que les autres
mais moins nombreux qu'avant donc ça
peut permettre une petite mobilisation
accrue
est-ce qu'on a une idée jonathan des
ressorts possible de cette abstention
oui alors dans le baromètre un plusieurs
pistes sont explorées on va aller on va
les regarder en détail pour près d'un
tiers des personnes interrogées 1 ne pas
voter s'explique par un désintérêt de la
politique un tout simplement vient
ensuite pour 24 % des personnes
interrogées le fait de ne pas se
reconnaître ni dans le projet ni dans
les candidats est au même niveau 18%
pensent qu'il est inutile de se déplacer
parce que l'élection serait jouée
d'avancé acquise à la majorité
présidentielle donc voté ns ne servirait
à rien et enfin il ya 11 % des
répondants qui sont en jeu dans une
sorte d'entre deux il ne compte pas
aller voter car ils ne soutiennent pas
emmanuel macron mais ils ne veulent pas
non plus l'empêcher de gouverner voilà à
noter aussi que c'est les catégories
socioprofessionnelles où l'abstention
est la plus importante sont les jeunes
entre 18 et 34 ont et les foyers les
plus modestes deux électorats qui sont
particulièrement favorable à jean luc
mélenchon et marine le pen donc voilà
danger pour ces deux camps à l'approché
des élections merci jonathan pour tous
et ses détails pablo pino vivien
effectivement alors on est à moins de
deux semaines la mode isation des
électeurs elle sera peut-être tardive
mais si cette abstention se confirme on
vient de l'évoquer c'est clairement une
mauvaise nouvelle notamment pour jean
luc mélenchon et pour marine le pen
exactement parce que comme ça a été dit
c'est laisser leur électorat en fait qui
sont le plus susceptibles de s'abstenir
aux prochaines élections alors il ya des
efforts kankan et fr ils sont notables
notamment à gauche moi je veux dire cet
accord de la gauche la façon dont les
candidats de la nuque s essaye de
d'occuper le terrain à la fois
médiatiquement et mais enfin je veux
dire collectivement et localement
ils essayent ils ont essayé de faire
exister alors leur stratégie ça a été
passé pour pour la pour les candidats de
la nuque ps c'est de se ranger derrière
jean-luc mélenchon et de dire il faut
que jean luc mélenchon soit premier
ministre c'est là que sont beaucoup
beaucoup d' affiches de ces de ses
candidats et candidates jean luc
mélenchon est à est à égalité en fait
qu'est ce qui est très étonnant à voir
sur des affiches pour les législatives
je ne sais pas si cette si cette
stratégie de communication peut peut
payer de dire que c'est un troisième
tour aussi électorale ce que refuse de
faire de l'autre côté de l'échiquier
politique marine le pen l on al
impression j'ai écouté un plusieurs de
ses interviews dans l'impression que
c'est un peu joué d'avancé et que elle
elle joue pas la gagne elle joue
dernière fois j'entends des mots jordan
bardella qui disait j'espère qu'on va
avoir un groupe donc je leur en donne
encore la
156 commencer oui je sais c'est quand
même énorme par rapport aux 8
qui vise le poste de premier ministre et
qui le répète c'est une négation mais
même dans leurs rangs les insoumis
commence à se dire que l'effectif sera
efficace cette stratégie on l'a vu parce
qu'il a imposée tout il a occupé
l'espace médiatique vous avez raison on
n'a parlé que de lui ça a été très
simple à comprendre mais là il est en
train de se murmurait chez les insoumis
que cette stratégie est partie bientôt
et que les français commencent à
comprendre qu'il ne serait jamais à
matignon et donc vous voyez le côté vote
utile va pas vraiment marché dans ces
cas là si on regarde les cotes
d'adhésion de marine le pen et de jean
luc mélenchon la cote d'adhésion de
marine le pen elle est à 35 % est en
baisse de trois points et puis on va
avoir ensuite la cote d'adhésion de jean
luc mélenchon qui baissent plus encore
que marine le pen puisqu'il est à 29 %
avec une baisse de 6 points est ce que
ça veut dire erwan lestrohan que
ça va forcément impacter le vote aux
législatives parce que pablo viens de
dire il détend en grand sur la photo
dans à peu près toutes les
circonscriptions donc est ce qu'on peut
faire aussi une façon aussi binaire
bombe à la popularité de jean luc
mélenchon est en baisse donc y aura
moins de jours pour voter pour les
candidats
de la nuque ou delà du ps non mais c'est
ce que vous disiez c'est qu'il ya
peut-être un essoufflement de cette
stratégie de mobilisation par la
victoire et pas par le vote de
témoignages cette stratégie de
mobilisation pour remporter matignon
peut-être qu'elle s'essouffle peut être
aussi que les affaires taha abou hafs ou
du burkini à grenoble ont un peu
détériorée le l'union des différentes
forces de gauche parce qu'on le voit
maintenant plus de 50 % des
sympathisants socialistes et 50% des
sympathisants europe écologie les verts
était satisfait de l'arrivée d'elisabeth
borne à matignon donc on a quand même
des liens à gauche qui se détériore un
peu et autres éléments c'est ce qui
était dit de la présentation du
baromètre c'est uniquement 34% des
français qui disent qu'ils connaissent
bien les candidats dans leur
circonscription
là ce que ça monte mais assez peut-être
plus intéressant pour mélanie baisse
c'est que l'étiquette va beaucoup
compter et tandis que les personnalités
sont pas connues c'est un vote qui va
beaucoup jouer à l'étiquette et on peut
se rappeler des scrutins intermédiaires
qui a eu pendant la crise sanitaire les
municipales qui a été une écurie tu es
une élection deux sortants les
régionales ou les sous casier de tous
les sortants ont été reconduits donc on
va voir quand même un scrutin avec un
poids de l'étiquette qui qui n'est pas
nul et là où le calcul pour jean luc
mélenchon peut lui être défavorable
c'est qu'il a dépassé 30% des suffrages
exprimés à la présidentielle dont
uniquement 80 circonscriptions sur 577
donc on est quand même qu'il a donc on
est sur un vote très localisés et une
capacité à être majoritaire qui est
quand même relativement il petit et puis
avec quand même un certain nombre de
dissension on va dire à gauche par
exemple on peut parler de françois
hollande qui tente de peser dans cette
campagne des législatives il était dans
son ancienne circonscription en corrèze
on va voir quelques images était
accompagné de son ancien premier
ministre et ministre de l'intérieur
bernard cazeneuve pour soutenir la
candidate socialiste
dissidente françois hollande l'ancien
prêt à la république qui s'en est pris
au programme de jean luc mélenchon
l'écoutent mais ça n'est pas mon avis un
programme capable de convaincre et
surtout s'il était appliqué imaginons
qu'il y ait une majorité nu ce programme
compte tenu de l'importance des dépenses
qu'il prévoit compte tenu des promesses
qu'il fait bien sûr se heurterait la
réalité c'est-à-dire serait incapable de
pouvoir être exécuté alex égèrement ce
n'est pas le seul à apporter ce discours
sur la faisabilité ou l'irréalisme du
programme de jean luc mélenchon et c'est
un discours qui est efficace qui
rappelle également celui qui avait été
tenu par rapport à la candidate marine
le pen en dernière en dernière ligne
droite avant le le second tour et je
vous rejoins quand vous dites que
certainement les affaires taha bois est
également la question du burkini à
grenoble ont pu impacter évidemment
l'unité de la nuit baisse mais aussi
tout simplement ça renvoie aussi au
programme au fond à un moment où c'était
une course de fond il y à un
essoufflement qui est due aussi à la
répétition des outrances de de jean luc
mélenchon parce que c'était très bien
trouvé au début évidemment mais à force
de le répéter deux ou trois fois il y a
un effet qui s'estompe mon bout d'un
moment assez surtout quand on comprend
qu'en fait chacun les socialistes les
communistes les verts on va faire un
groupe avec leur nom avec leur loyer
donc en fait la nuque baisse l or a
existé pendant la campagne les insoumis
18000 y aura un intergroupe c'est à dire
qu'on pourra apparaître sous cette
étiquette mais rien n'est moins sûr
thomas donc finalement on retrouvera les
fragilités voilà les fragiles aux séries
mais il y aura un cadre pour discuter
ils ont déjà hier ils ont lancé un
parlement de cette nouvelle union
populaire écologique et sociale donc on
peut imaginer que en fait ce qu'il faut
voir c'est que les différences entre les
différentes composantes de la deûle à nu
baisse c'est vraiment un papier à
cigarette ces quelques questions qui
sont des questions importantes 1 et
qu'on peut pas mettre sous le tapis
comme la question notamment du nucléaire
ou de l'europe exactement est là il
était exactement mais enfin je peux vous
dire c'est quand même pas le coeur du
programme enfin le programme ils ont je
sais plus combien 600 propositions puis
on a 90 pendant mais se sentant tout à
fait j'entends plus ce sont des sujets
très importants mais pour lequel ils ont
dit bon bah là vous pourrez garder vos
votes après juste je trouve ça un peu
fort de café de la part de de françois
hollande en fait de dire euh oui c'est
ceux des mots trop où tout ça est par
exemple moi je rappelle que françois
hollande s'est fait élire sur un slogan
qui l'a répété à l'envi pendant la
campagne présidentielle de 2012 qui
était mon ennemi c'est la finance donc
si ça c'était pas un slogan populiste à
l'envi je trouve ça et maintenant ils
donnent des leçons vous dire vous savez
la gauche de gouvernement c'est
différent tous à des packs table je
trouve ça un peu un peu
[Musique]
quand même complètement démonétisé
celles présentées
il avait l'occasion de se présenter être
candidat il a hésité jusqu'au dernier
moment enfin il a fait je me suspense il
ne l'a pas fait c'est vrai que certains
vont peut-être aussi les frais des cités
parce qu'en fait ce que veulent les
français c'est ne pas se retrouver dans
une situation de blocage et tels que
jean luc mélenchon a présenté les choses
c'est finalement un bras de fer et une
situation de blocage c'est drôle c'est
ce que disait jonathan dupriez tout à
l'heure il ya les 11 % de français qui
disent on veut pas macron mais on veut
pas non plus voté pour les autres pour
pas le mettre en situation de blocage je
termine avec les personnalités
politiques les plus populaires et ce
sont deux anciens premiers ministres qui
trustent les deux premières places de ce
baromètre edouard philippe à 47 % de
popularité et jean castex et c'est la
première fois que vous le tester dans
cet exercice là entend évidemment
qu'ancien premier ministre qui est à 40%
est-ce qu'ils sont plus haut que
d'habitude commet il se situe par
rapport à la halle à leur popularité
habituel en tout cas pour edouard
philippe alors edouard philippe avait
fini son mandat de premier ministre à
48% nos bonnes opinions dont qui reste
dans les mêmes eaux jean castex gagnent
4 points par rapport à mai al avril
c'est cette prise de recul par rapport à
la vie politique qui suscite peut-être
un peu plus de bienveillance qui est
intéressant c'est de voir constitue
peut-être dans une période aussi de
redémarrage ou de réorganisation des
institutions et que les français
montrent de la trêve pour les figures
connues des institutions françaises donc
cet intérêt pour les premiers ministres
sortants il est aussi intéressant au
sens du récit mac rognan pour la france
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles
emmanuel macron dispose aussi d'un
certain crédit dans l'opinion c'est que
au delà de la macro ni il ya peu de
figures qui émergent et notamment dans
l'opposition alexia germond vous avez
intégré le parti horizon d'edouard
philippe
qu'est ce que ça nous donne comme
pouvoir cette popularité d'après ou
d'abord c'est pas une popularité qui est
surprenante même quand on voit les
évolutions parce que je crois qu'il ya
deux choses qui résonne quand vous
discutez avec les gens c'est à la fois
la vision le fait que ça soit pour un
temps long parce que c'est quand même ce
qui est ce qui intéresse dans la
démarche revenir aux idées dire que les
partis politiques on en a besoin dans
une structuration démocratique justement
pour pouvoir retisser ce lien parce
qu'on est tous d'accord autour de la
table pour dire que la fracture
démocratique la fracture politique est
elle est flagrante donc il ya un vrai
travail de fond à refaire que les
institutions de la vème été fait pour
cela et ça c'est quelque chose qui parle
avec aussi un style edouard philippe qui
est un style assez direct après on aime
ou on n'aime pas ça c'est un autre sujet
mais où en tout cas les français pendant
une période qui a été compliqué avec le
confinement ont eu le sentiment de
quelqu'un qui
savait qu'elles étaient les options et
quand ils ne savaient pas l'adie est
d'ailleurs aussi de façon assez
transparente donc c'est un style qui est
un peu en rupture est certainement très
proche aussi avec pas mal pas mal
d'empathie après par rapport à votre
question
qu'est ce qu'il apporte il apporte des
choses différentes parce que ce sont des
sensibilités différentes dans la
majorité présidentielle
et je crois que quand on dit que la
majorité elle elle est vraiment pluriel
il y a sur la question de la sécurité
sur la question du rapport à la dette
aujourd'hui on n'est pas du tout sur ces
thématiques là dans la campagne mais il
y à des approches qui sont différentes
et quand on sera à nouveau sur les idées
je pense qu'on verra des différences
entre eux que mon approche
macro nien l'art m
renaissance et des approches modem qui
sont différentes et des approches
horizons et donc peut-être un ferment de
division pablo je ne sais pas c'est la
division mais en tout cas la question de
la succession en fait d' emmanuel macron
je pense qu'elle peut elle commence à se
jouer dès maintenant et effectivement je
pense que et doit flipper dans les
starting blocks même si je pense que
intégrer ce type de classement de
personnalités politiques préférées des
français c'est toujours un peu à double
tranchant parce que pour moi c'est un
peu un truc de retraités c'est un peu
bon bah vous partez vous teindre pluriel
populaire plan des retraités jamais
exactement quand vous regardez vous
savez c'était et c'est toujours florent
pagny jean jacques goldman des gens
direction n'attend plus rien en fait
aujourd'hui quand l'une des belle
carrière j'en convient tout à fait mais
de qui on n'attend plus rien donc mais
bon ceci ceci tout ceci me that an
peut-être encore des choses exactement
je pense que j'ai encore des choses à
attendre de d'edouard philippe la
question c'est comment est-ce qui va se
positionner alors sur le fond j'entends
que il a sa sensibilité qui est tout à
fait notable la question c'est la
stratégie et la tactique qui va mettre
en place pour ben entre guillemets tuer
ses concurrents parce que va y avoir du
monde au portillon qui va vouloir
prendre la place d'emmanuel maquereau en
2000 en 2027 avec des élections
intermédiaires qui vont être très
importantes je pense notamment aux
élections municipales
avec dans les grandes villes des gens
qui vont se positionner à paris à nantes
c'est une différence très forte
exactement la reine c'est qu'il ya
vraiment un ancrage ayache territoriales
cela les élus locaux qui est réel on
suivra ça dans les prochains mois merci
beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat a bientôt évidemment sur
public sénat sens